let me move on to uh next guest what do
you think about the subject yeah first
thing to say I just think people
genuinely made some really good points
in a really erudite way and I think it's
really well hosted man I appreciate it I
mean I'm not changing it
yeah man and like you got two good
effects good job you're not on radio you
need to be seen as well wouldn't it
seems yeah I know yeah yeah so you're on
the right meet you're on the right
Medium you're on the right medium baby
all right yeah so look um I don't think
there's any hard and fast rules based on
gender uh so back in the day me when I
went out with like with my mates and I
just go in bars and [ __ ] and just like
chat to girls yeah and I had nuts if I
fancied a girl boom I'm going up to her
sometimes that have worked sometimes she
just tell me to jog on you know what I
mean and hey that's her loss isn't it
yeah so do you feel like okay like in
your time would you say that
um it was hard for like the average guy
out there to get girls or do you think
when you're looking at do you look when
you look at Society now like maybe a
guy's younger than you now and when
they're out there trying to like you
know get books or get a girlfriend or
whatever do you think that is maybe a
little bit tougher these days because I
honestly think that it's tougher and I
think that the the the
requirements have risen I think what
we've got now is an American dating
system heavily yeah heavily back in the
day yeah you had a girlfriend man boom
you went out on a few dates like you met
some girl in a club or some [ __ ] like
that yeah you go out and then you'd be
together and boom that's you right but
even in America back in the day in the
90s and [ __ ] but in New York people were
dating do you understand it wasn't like
oh that's my girl it'd be like you know
we yeah I'm dating and that was they
were cool and everyone's upfront about
that [ __ ] yeah but listen now you yeah
thing that pisses me off so much and
it's not a gender thing yeah like
ghosting man that's just disrespectful
experience
do you know but I feel you because this
happens to every guy every guy knows
this thing and you know the funny thing
yeah the girls are laughing and you know
why the girls are laughing because it
doesn't really happen to them like that
unless
unless they're they're chasing after
Chad and Tyrone and Charlie Tyrone yeah
I'm always a Tyrone hold on let me let
me finish the challenge Tyrone has a lot
of options yeah if he can get you that
means he's got at least 10 of you that's
what it is so that's why the girls are
oh I object yeah we know who you've been
you get me so because usually as we
already agreed from the start 80 percent
of women are going over to the top 20 to
10 of guys so obviously those top 20 to
10 percent of guys have got a monopoly
they can get any girl on this trip like
it's not a big deal but the average guy
out there bro like he's the average guy
and really and truly that bro I get
messages from guys all the time bro like
the average guy with the average girl
the average girl is not looking at that
guy he's like bro I don't need to date
you but I've got Instagram fam
but I said though
but if you've got got all these places
and you go outside you could be a parent
and you could still go outside do you
know what I'm saying that yeah
someone on Instagram then I meet them on
Instagram
calm down like at the end of the day we
live in a social media age yeah people
meet on people wait hold on it doesn't
listen it doesn't matter listen stop
talking it doesn't matter if you think
it's fake but it is what it is yeah
people meet online there's dating apps
hinge POF Tinder bamboo all these things
email whatever bro like come on
um Snapchat is social media as well
remember them the messages that
disappear that's social media as well uh
Instagram brother it happens all the
time why did bro they've got songs about
sliding in the DM if they if that didn't
happen bro no one would talk about it so
it doesn't matter if you think it's fake
it happens it happens
so what I'm saying like at my age listen
I've I've been out with a lot of women
and trust me I'm saying I'm an actor I
I'm doing well believe I'm [ __ ] I'm a
successful fella man and I love me boom
yeah oh my God no serious I mean I
should self-love I ain't [ __ ] about
I'm serious oh we believe you so where I
am now yeah if someone just Ducks out of
something like I'm I'm indifferent to
this [ __ ] trust me
I ain't joking I'm indifferent to that
I'm beyond that [ __ ] now man if I go out
like I went out listen I wouldn't have
some a Tinder date yeah and this is that
no this is not me digging out women you
know I was out with this woman yeah and
she was a bit of a doofus yeah she gives
it others so many times I heard this
like again uh oh you're an actor yeah
yeah oh how do I know you're not acting
now is that because I'm having a drink
with you like what do you do can I ask
you a question yeah sorry just out of
pure curiosity how old are you again 51
okay and you're single yeah okay so
at like the stage you're at in life are
you looking for a like a partner in life
or are you just passed that point
because like not past any point but I
ain't actively no no no no do you want
kids Nama okay so what are you looking
for in life do you just want to just
like just just leave your seed enough
women and then just add this no no
you've got me wrong so with the greatest
respect I mean I'm just I'm just asking
what you just hold on you just asked him
has he got kids he said no you asked him
does he want kids he said no then you
said so what are you trying to do leave
your seed in women and I'm not in it I
thought she better just passing up with
women that's that's what I thought no no
no no okay
I didn't mean it like that I just meant
like are you just trying to you know
date here cool sleep around that was
nice basically it's all right you can
call it right leave the question open to
say what do you want like yeah rather
than do you want to sleep around yeah
yeah yeah no I'm not trying to act if
they do anything I'm on yeah I'm I'm
having Tinder dates and [ __ ] like that
and some of them go well some of them
don't what I prioritize is my career my
mates I've got a good life you know what
I mean I'll ask you a question yeah and
because you're an actor have you ever
found that women have
um like as in the whole high standards
thing with the dating have you had women
be like oh you're an actor so how much
do you make then like oh have you been
on the big screen and as in like have
you found women have expectations of you
that were ridiculous and you're like
okay what the hell is this I suppose
whatever you're trying to get back to
the question yeah like whatever you're
doing like but I you know as an actor do
you get uh I've been there for 26 years
I would do it for the rest of my life
that's what I do bang right but you do
you get asked the same muggy questions
as an actor yeah man does it do your
head in yeah it does what's a high
standard that has annoyed you what do
you mean in high standard what sense
like as in because of the topic we're
talking about is the Modern Woman want
too much expectations what's an
expectations
and this is not me being bitter I'm just
answering your question right yeah right
so one of my ex-girlfriends and I I was
heartbroken man but listen she lived in
her house in sorry 1.5 million I used to
mow the [ __ ] lawn like quite a lot
yeah sorry I'm gonna stop swearing but
like that's how I communicate yeah but
like she had a Range Rover Evo foreign
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible